occasional party we're gonna do some
country star confessions okay ready yeah
[Music]
same oh and of the work we drank
where's your guilty pleasure
I don't know I can make like food time
so milkshakes
okay and kind of milkshake vanilla or
mint chocolate chip
would that be your ultimate cheat no - I
don't know what's your open pizza
yeah good pizza okay everybody likes
Pete yeah any particular kind I like
Hawaiian pizza I like supreme pizza
pineapple now a lot of people go for the
pineapple
[Music]
who was your first celebrity crush oh I
think Mariah Carey was up there laughter
today right but she's still hot yeah but
back when she was first coming out
[Music]
sleep
what's your go-to karaoke song how men
lie but I love Neil Diamond so ask me
carefully
Taji
[Music]
what's the one song you wish you wrote
and record it troubadour
oh right yeah that's the basic song and
you can always you know even if you're
you know you past 25 you say I still
feel 25 most of the time it's just a
great song
[Music]
another
[Music]
another DEATH to a country song what was
the last thing you cried watching TV oh
I what about a movie
sure I was hard to get through Tom Hanks
as mr. Rogers I thought that oh right I
thought would really give me room Hanks
just devastated but every time I mean I
cried during fourth go what is your most
prized possession
let's get romantic summer I'm marrying
her I don't want to lose summer that is
the man who knows what he's doing yeah
well play yeah